play clock just about got to zero pennx
gets the snap off takes a shot for
mcmiller he's got it theone
for
pennx going to take a shot down the
field looking for
Odun and he hold it in they just blocked
their tails off for the running back
Nixon in the back field pennx throws
toward the corner of the end zone that
one
is C so as wide receiver can make a play
down the field no Jaylen McMillan but
Bernard is talented so he's stepping in
now toward the end zone Co what a throw
Punk
touchdown he's a really good cover
[Music]
Corner penck going deep adun turned
around found the ball touchdown Jaylen p
in motion PX pum fake and now launches a
dart down to the edro Cook tou down
Giles Jackson joins the party and this
is the zipped right around him final
minute in this first
quarter pressure picked up again
launching for the endzone caught
touchdown jayen
poke penck backpedals goes right
downfield and a traffic it's poke with a
leaping
catch launching for the end zone for
again being
patient he's now working the comedy
shots very nice oh the sarge has all
kinds of tricks up his sleeve going deep
and wide open jayen pul flags are down
pulk will take it the distance there it
is sets up for a pick play doesn't it
they go fade the other way it is
touchdown Jaylen invert Bill said down
there in the end
yeah penck from the pocket spins
free trying to mirror C Williams
creativity launches the
end no signal did he hold it Utah great
at forcing third down and Longs penck
with a shot down the sideline and what
hands this is the ninth straight pass
play for Washington penck going far side
and Zone o dun
Revenge he's got as many targets to
as Odun he's on the sideline this time
panx panon shot down the middle it's a
touchdown Odun a minute now of the first
half as pennx heaves it down into the
endone C touchdown Odun for a second
time
tonight penx looks to the other side and
goes to his reliable weapon when in
doubt dial up
Odun just playing to get to a bowl game
they want another game in their career
here penck play action looking to go
over the top he catapults it down the
field on dun's
alone in that game in October he kept
rby holding his chest after that took a
shot to the midsection Here Comes lay
pressure right up the middle penics back
pedals and Chucks it for McMillan who
gathers it in and is knocked out ins 437
before half time penic and the Huskies
trying to add to this two touchdown lead
from the pocket looking for Odun two
guys were on him that nth 100yd game
this season for
Odun caught eight balls the first game
has seven tonight
pennx downfield and the catch is made by
McMillan penx lobs into the end zone
touchdown Clon
MO
has time short throw catch made McMillan
first down
Washington